in America's election headquarters
tonight the orchestra starts late but we
are 57 days from the midterm elections
and because of some shifting poll
numbers in various races both the House
and Senate are believed to be in play
tonight we have Fox team coverage
Mike Emanuel here in Washington looks at
the Republican prospects for keeping
control of the Senate
correspondent Peter Doocy is in Orange
County California with what appear to be
better odds for Democrats to flip the
house didn't Peter good evening Bret
Democrats finally deployed their most
valuable weapon on the campaign trail
President Obama and they sent him here
for his first big rally of the cycle
because they believe that this is where
the most Republican members are the most
vulnerable Democrats need to flip two
dozen seats to win back the house and
believe they can pick off seven here in
Southern California if we don't step up
things get worse one Democrat the former
president is trying to help Katie Porter
hundreds of volunteers turned out for
Obama's rally near the 45th district
where Porter is trying to beat
congresswoman Mimi Walters in a place
where voters have never elected a
Democrat they're concerned about
Congress's failure to provide a check
and balance on the Trump administration
Walter's the incumbent insists she
already does that breaking from Trump on
issues like tariffs and family
separations I won the last race by 17
points and the president lost by five
that's a 23 point swing and she doesn't
think lifelong Republicans will send a
liberal lawmaker to DC my opponent for
example is an Elizabeth Warren socialist
those policies do not play well in
Orange County the Porter argues what
really doesn't play well in this
district with high state and local taxes
is the GOP tax reform plans cap on state
and local tax deductions
the way Walter sees it that tax plan
will keep Orange County red small
business owners that I talked to tell me
that the biggest challenge they're
having right now is trying to find a
place because their businesses are
growing so fast they do not want to go
back to the Obama years but it might be
returned to the Pelosi years of entire
red regions like Orange County start to
turn blue and it appears that voters
here are open to the idea of seeing her
with the speaker's gavel again because
the Fox News Power Rankings just moved
California's 45th from leaning
Republican to a toss-up Brett will
follow them all Peter Doocy live in
Orange County Peter thanks